(air whooshing)
♪ Tea with Garyvee ♪
(bright upbeat music)
♪ Just text your question
and what's stressing ♪
♪ 'cause your sipping tea
with tea with Garyvee ♪
- Good morning, good morning, good morning
just promoting a little event I'm doing
with Matt Higgins on
LinkedIn, all right posted.
Good morning everybody,
hope everybody is super well.
Really appreciate you being
here with us this morning.
Let's get right into it
today is just an hour unfortunately,
'cause I've some business to attend.
So, let's get right into the show,
obviously like always,
take a screenshot, share it on Twitter,
share it on Facebook, good
morning, good morning,
Tahir Shane Nana what's good? Taylor
Hi, Maria and Daniela,
- Morning Gary, how are you?
- Good morning, good morning guys,
what's kicking?
- Yeah my name is Maria Legarda
and I am an actress and a content creator.
- And I'm Daniela Legarda I'm
a singer and content creator.
- So we are here today because a big part
of our brand is together,
as well as we have our
own separate brands,
since I'm an actress and she is a singer.
And last year was the
hardest year of our life,
where we went through
severe depression, anxiety,
after losing my brother, all while having
to do it in the public eye.
In the brink of our career taking off,
I had just booked an amazing series
here in the States, she was on tour.
So we really persevered through that,
we were able to start a
non for profit organization
in the name of my brother in Colombia,
open a Baron clothing company.
I mean, we've been
really, really doing great
in our careers as content creators.
We have millions of followers,
everything is going good.
So our biggest question for you now is.
- Is as my sister told you,
we are already very strong
in the Latin market.
We wanna figure out how
to be able to cross over
into the American audience
and also reach the Latinx
without neglecting our Latino
audience that we already have.
What do you recommend?
How can we do that?
We also wanna be able to show the brands,
that you know we have
such a loyal following.
We have fans that will
buy what we promote.
What do you recommend?
- So what's great,
first of all, I'm sorry about
the passing of your brother
I'm sure it was
- Thank you.
- Ridiculously difficult and
congratulations on everything.
- Thank you.
- The good news is, Becky G and Bad Bunny
we've proven this already,
you can cross over not neglect the base
and easily play out that
Spanglish Latin kind of
crossover play it really is
truly a couple of things.
One, it's patience, two
because really it is patience.
It takes time, right?
I love how everybody's like,
"oh Bad Bunny."
And like people that
(laughs)
have been fucking with Bad bunny
have been fucking with
him for five years, right?
- So, like--
- For a while now.
- Right? So like for me, I
think it's a couple of things,
one, similar to let's just use Bad Bunny
or Balvin or Nicky Jam,
it is about collaboration
with U.S. superstars.
There's so many U.S
actors, actresses content,
and definitely music, right?
That desperately wanna tap
in to the Latin culture.
So they need you as much as you need them.
So I think it's having the humility
and the tact to reach out
to some of those artists
that you wanna collab with, right?
Whether it's skits on IGTV or YouTube
with a famous actor, or actress,
or whether it's obviously
a song and a collaboration.
I genuinely believe that at the
level that you're playing at
it is collaboration crossover,
the brands will come.
The brands thing, let me tell
you exactly how it happens.
We put Becky G in our Super
Bowl spot this year for Sobre.
Right? Once you do that, then everybody's
considering you all the time.
It's just one moment in time.
And so I wouldn't pander
as much to the brand play.
I would pander much more to the artists
that can help you cross over
and I would do a ton of collaborations.
YouTube stars, TikTok stars, and obviously
actual actors and actresses in your field
that have more of an American audience.
- Yeah, do you recommend for
example like in TikTok right?
My American audience is second heaviest
after my Colombian audience.
Do you recommend that we start
in our TikTok and Instagram?
Also dropping like just
English content ourselves?
'Cause that's a really big part of us.
I mean, we were raised like this.
- Of course--
- But we don't wanna (mumbles).
I feel like when we do it,
our Latin audience is like,
"No dra dra we want (mumbles)
- Of course. That's the
most extreme language
and I see it every day.
And my answer, whether
it's someone in Asia
or someone in Colombia,
or somewhere anywhere else
is post one more time a day.
- Okay.
- Okay
Like literally making a
video right now, and being,
"Look, guys, we are ambitious girls,
"and we're going there.
"So here's what we're about to do.
"We're gonna post more often,
"and sometimes it's in Spanish,
"and sometimes it's in English.
"And sometimes it's gonna be in Spanglish,
"the way we actually talks (mumbles)."
I'm Russian. I'm with
my parents right now.
We start the sentence in Russian
and we ended in English, right?
So I think you post more,
and you make the announcement
that you're gonna post more so that
everybody doesn't feel like
they're missing out on anything.
Also, I would 100% when
you do English content,
pay somebody, it's not
expensive to transcribe it
and caption it in Spanish.
- Okay, 'cause we put subtitles
on everything right now.
- Great.
- We recently started doing it
in order to (mumbles) American audience.
- Yeah, we do it in Spanish
and we'll do 'em English.
But we're just tryna figure
out how we can target more,
our culture, of the Latinx
and really just go there
with the English community
without making people feel neglected.
- You've got this
transcribing, captioning,
collaborations and more content, your set.
A whole audience is asking
for your social handles.
So what's your TiKToK and Instagrams.
- Mine I am misslegarda on everything
- And I am Danielalegarda.
- Spell Legarda just so
that they can find you.
- L-E-G-A-R-D-A
- Good luck, ladies. Thanks for bring on.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much Gary.
Have a good one
- This tea is good this morning.
Collabo is the key Lloyd Barclay,
thank you so much for joining us.
Kazeck what is good?
What about Aussies What
number do we need to text?
Kaz, We're gonna start taking people
from the Twitter is
where we're gonna start
pulling international people from.
For Tea with GaryVee.
So if you have a question,
please go to Twitter
and hashtag Tea with GaryVee.
Jay, how are you?
- Good morning, Gary.
- It's great to see you again.
- Healthy energy here
from Summit New Jersey.
- It's great to see you.
- I have been a big fan
and follower of yours.
Since I first saw one of your
billboard boards on (mumbles).
- Hey Jay, your audio I hear muffled
anyway to fix that you think?
- Let me see.
It's down a little bit better?
- It does hear better keep going.
- Okay. So I'm a 62
year young entrepreneur.
And one of the things
that has been amazing.
So I do have a question for you.
- Yep (laughs)
- The story to it is, for the past year,
thanks to Claude inviting
me to come into VaynerMedia.
And then working with Danny
and all of your peeps over there.
For the past year, I've been
embedded in VaynerMedia,
working with everybody
on their well being,
this little machine over here,
this body composition machine.
The reason why I reached out to you
is because when I started
watching your videos
about what you're doing
with Michael Jordan,
and I saw what you're doing
in transforming your well being,
I am curious to see what you
guys are doing over there.
So twice a month, I'm at VaynerMedia,
I've now had the opportunity to be
with over 500 of your peeps.
And really what's been
interesting has not been just
talking to them about
the body composition,
but in this conversation, of finding out
kind of like where their thoughts are,
what they gonna do, whether
they have challenges.
And what's great is we have the data,
but it really becomes a conversation
about what they've been
wanting to create in their life
and one of the amazing data
I got from your team is,
I was a little concerned when I was there.
I'm like," Okay, I'm 62
these guys are all young."
I deal well with people that are younger,
but I was like,"Maybe they
won't hear what I have to say."
And what I found is the
generosity of millennials
with people that have other experience.
I think there's an amazing opportunity
to create and collaborate.
I've heard you say that in
different conversations,
and I would pick from the interview
that you're doing over there.
So my question that is, during
these challenging times,
during this window of opportunity,
what do you see, instead
of people that are older
that think that they can't
they don't know (mumbles)?
What do you see as an opportunity
to get more people that are
younger and older and all ages?
What kind of like ageless entrepreneurs,
how do you see that being something
that can really be a catalyst for change
and creating opportunities
for this challenging times?
- Yeah I appreciate it.
And I think obviously you follow closely
and you've been under the roof
of our culture in the office,
and so I believe the
generosity that you're feeling
is that my organization knows
that if we're gonna be woke,
and we're gonna be so amazing.
This is not just being
open to other people's,
races, sexual orientations,
lifestyle choices,
I think, no question, the
number one group of people
in our culture right now
that are underestimated
and suppressed for what
they can bring to the table
is the over 55 set I
mean, people completely
and at least in my world, are
completely under estimating
the impact, the value, the wisdom,
the jokes of like, not
knowing how to use technology.
I laugh listening, my organization
is quite liberal and very
loving and I love that.
I love the warmth that
comes into our organization,
but the one place they don't see it
is they wildly underestimate
48, 57, 63, 71, 82, 84.
And so I think there's a
lot of ageism, I really do.
And it's a passion of mine,
and we're starting to hire that way.
We're going through a ton of resumes
and we're gonna start hiring
creatives and strategists
that are over 60.
You live in Summit New Jersey,
which is a nice suburb of New York City,
we know that there's an
extraordinary amount of
retired actually have
finished their careers.
Ad executives from the heyday of ad world,
who actually just woke up and said,
"Wait a minute, I'm 63
years young, I'm bored."
We can hire them at good prices,
'cause they're gonna be
thrilled to be energized
and do something.
They don't need the
salaries they used to make
and we're excited about the
impact they're gonna make
on our youth culture.
Let's use this video
as as a heat to action.
If you're 50 to 90, and you
feel like you still have it,
the answer is you do. If you actually have
the hunger to produce an impact.
This is an incredible time.
And so to answer your question directly,
I think they need to be
producing content at scale,
videos on LinkedIn and
YouTube about things
that are forever true Jay,
it's incredible to me how
many things are true at 44
that I learned at 22, 32, 37.
And then that goes on and on and on,
and so it's literally just a perspective.
There's so many people that dwell
and think they were born
into a bad situation.
And instead of seeing the opportunity
that the dirt under their
fingernails allow them,
they decide that the
machine and life is unfair,
and they've been handed a bad hand,
and they don't know how to play that hand.
And the reason poker is such a game
that I think attracts people
to it, besides the math
is it's a game of life.
You can get a seven and nine
off suit and navigate a victory
and we see that in the world all the time.
And that's kind of how
I see ageism right now,
I know this about you Jay,
I see you navigating through social,
I know the impact you've
had in the office,
you'll live another 40 fucking year,
like what are we doing here?
I don't understand that
people don't understand
they're at halftime, they think it's over,
and I'm blown away by that
and a, I want them to start realizing
that they've got decades left
and b, I want the 15,
25, 35 and 45 year olds
that are watching here
to realize how much value
they can extract from the individuals,
Okay, your grandma or
your uncle or a mentor
may not know how to be
crunk on fucking TikTok,
but they can teach you a ton of shit
that you will not know
for another two decades.
So I hope they're inspired to make,
it's about putting it out.
- The big thing I talk to people
'cause I get a chance to navigate
and help them in their well being,
in business ideas it's
interesting watching,
I've watched every one of these episodes.
And what was interesting was
and it's funny 'cause the other day,
when you did a thing with
Chris Baar of Bar nine,
I got so inspired because
I've been speaking around the country
ever since Biggest Loser.
And like you know being the speaker,
when you get in front of an
audience, it's so powerful.
You pull off their energy
and when I'm with people one to one,
you pull off their energy.
And instead of trying to do some video,
it was like, "This feels weird."
Because I'm like talking to a machine.
But what I found was,
and I called Chris back,
'cause I said, "Look, I gotta tell you,
"what Gary said, makes so much sense.
"It's like exercise, it
doesn't feel comfortable,
"the first time you do
it, but after a while,
"you feel better about it."
And if you come from a place
about you giving to somebody,
then you don't obsess about like,
"How do I look? And how do I sound?
So wanna --
- 100%
- One of the big things I've
gotten listening to you,
is most people know me
for health and well being.
But I've lived my life as
a frickin' entrepreneur.
I've been in startups, I've
been a branding director
for a 6 billion dollar corporation.
I've had the sit deflected backup,
and I wasn't speaking about my business,
entrepreneurship and
employment shifting (mumbles)
what the hell is going
on. So thank you for that.
- You're welcome, brother.
I'm gonna try to get to
a bunch people today,
so I only got 45 more minutes.
So I'm gonna jump off a little early,
but I appreciate that.
And that's what happened
with me with wine.
Jay, thanks for being on.
Everybody, what Jay just said,
is what happened with me with wine.
I was like," wait a minute,
"I wanna talk about
entrepreneurship and business."
That's what I've actually
been my whole life.
I've been an entrepreneur,
hustler, you know, grinder,
flipper, businessman, long
before I was a wine guy.
And, even though that's
what I was first known for,
you can always make that transition.
So if you're watching right now,
and you wanna be known
for what you actually are,
versus what--
and by the way I see this a
lot with attractive people,
both guys and girls.
Like they're known for being attractive,
they may blew up on Instagram,
but meanwhile, they've got so many skills
and so many other things.
Start making content about
what you want to be known for,
not what the audience
is giving you like for,
it's gonna lead to a much happier life.
The reality is, is that,
it's not fun to be in the ecosystem
of just living for the like,
and so I just really, really
hope people understand that.
And yes, you will get far less likes.
When you're showing your huge guns,
you're gonna get 40, 000 likes,
and when you're talking
about architecture,
you may get 4, 000.
When you're showing a lot of skin
and looking sexy as fuck and poppin',
you're gonna get a lot of likes.
When you start talking
about flowers you may not,
but the reality is you have to speak
what you're passionate about.
It's the only way to get to happiness.
And there's a lot of people
are unhappy right now,
'cause you're caught for
what they were known for,
and what they popped off for.
And now they're stuck
living for the likes.
Let's keep it going.
- Hello.
- How's it going?
- Good. Ben, how are you?
- I'm good. Thank you.
- My question is, I'm a graphic designer,
and I'm really hard on myself in terms of,
I don't like what I create.
So I'll have a really good idea.
But I'm always stuck in this mindset of
is not good enough, I need to do better,
I need to keep learning to improve
and that's hindering me ever investing
in what I want to put out there.
So I just wanna know
how do I get out of that kind of mindset?
- By realizing that means
that you're insecure
to other people's feedback,
or you grew up in an environment
that put you into a mindset,
whether that was parenting,
natural DNA, or the
neighborhood you grew up in,
and the people you
surrounded yourself with,
and you have to realize it's a ghost.
You have to realize it's a ghost.
You're not right, and more importantly,
everything is subjective.
Everything is subjective.
There is no right when it comes to art.
The reason I'm so fluid
with what I put out,
is some people think it's the greatest
and some people think it's dog shit.
Some people think I'm
repeating myself over and over.
I think other people think that
I'm so convicted in my truth
that it's inspirational.
My man, listen to me.
The reality is, is get out
of your own fucking head,
know that it's a ghost.
It's a ghost, it's not true.
It's complete insecurity.
And the way you get out of it is practice.
You've gotta find a way to
just hit enter and walk away.
Or to just ship it. It's
it's a fucking ghost.
It's not real, it's not. I promise you.
- Okay, so if I wanna put something
if I create something I wanna
get a physical version of it.
Is it just a case of just do?(mumbles)
- Just do it.
And are you looking to
sell that physical version?
Or looking to put in your house?
- A bit of both really (mumbles).
- I'm sorry, I apologize.
- I kind of have the insecurity of
I wanna buy something for myself.
So like an art print, for example.
But I'm like, it's not good enough.
Why should I buy it?
- You know, it's interesting.
what I think is for yourself,
you get to just decide you're
the judge and the jury.
But for the world, do not judge for them.
You don't get to judge for
them, that's the reality.
It's funny I've been
working with my best friend
on this thing Wine Texts that I'm sure
you've been hearing me promote for my dad.
Yesterday we went through
500 different wines to buy,
and I watch Brandon and
he overthinks things
and I'm like Brandon,
we don't get to decide
if this wine is great or not
great, it's the consumer.
And the reality is, like, for example,
today's gonna be a pinot noir.
It's a $52 pinot noir
that we're gonna sell
for like under 25 bucks.
That's a good time, Dustin
put up the wine Text
is a perfect example, though.
But it was a good discussion
and maps to yours.
Where I'm like, Brandon.
I like this Pinot noir style.
You don't like this pinot noir.
Rick does, Jen does, Stephen doesn't.
Everyone has their own palette.
And you need to realize that Ben,
that there's audacity in you
thinking it's wrong or right.
You need the humility to realize
they get to decide not us.
- Yeah, so it's just a
matter of whatever I do,
really has to be good enough
for me is just subjective.
Whether whoever put out (mumbles).
- Correct, somebody is
gonna always love it
and somebody's gonna always hate it.
This is coming down to you
leaning into two core things,
humility and self confidence,
everyday humility, self confidence.
Humility, you should make a
fucking piece of art right now
named humility and self confidence
and pin that shit on your fucking wall
and look at it every time
and see this fucking face
and then just make and post.
- I'll put your face next to it
and then I'll be my daily inspiration.
- Good, and I'll buy
it. I love you, buddy.
Take care. Cheers.
- Cheers,
- Good kid. Like that, dude.
I'm always gonna be yelling.
I love if Somebody stop
yelling at me, Gary.
I got good news for you.
I'm gonna be yelling to
the fucking end of Earth.
That is what I'm going to be doing,
'cause that yelling is
coming from the sweetest,
fucking sweetest, kindest, caringest place
you could ever imagine.
It might come out Jersey,
it might come out alpha.
It may come out like a
competitive fucker like I am,
but I promise you, where
this shit comes from,
Where this fucking seed comes from?
Is the fucking sweetest,
kindest, most empathetic,
caring, sympathetic fucking
energy you'll ever taste.
Lets keep it going.
- Hey, Gary. Good morning.
- Good morning, Krystal.
So, I own a sewing company in Nashville.
It's been growing for the last--
I'm just going to jump right into it.
It's been growing for the last like,
four and a half years or so.
I've bootstrapped from the beginning.
I've like taken up as
little space as possible.
And now finally, like signed a lease
on March 1st for a huge space.
Need every bit of it
when it's busy (chuckles)
My sewing company caters to entertainment,
all of my--
oh (laughs) exactly.
So then on March 3, we had a tornado,
like blow right by my window,
miss my business, knock out
like all kinds of other businesses, homes
and everything like F
the word tornado bad.
So for a week, week and a half,
everything was really shattered
and then we jumped straight
into COVID quarantine.
So all of my contracts canceled,
knitting any kind of sewing
for the next like six months,
I think festivals (mumbles) picks up
during June, July, August,
somewhere around there.
And so, like two weeks
ago, week and a half ago,
I sent you an email and I said,
"All right, I'm gonna do
exactly what you say to do.
(laughs)
"And I'm going to go full out."
And I had already started,
I built a website that had nothing to do
with my Nashville based business.
I just built like my name.com,
all of the things that I love,
and I'm gonna document
and chronicle every step
of what I'm going through and learning
in terms of sustainable fashion,
in terms of entrepreneurship,
in terms of taming my mustang horse.
All of these little things, right?
- I love.
- Few days later, the
Forbes article comes out
saying we need help sewing masks.
And I was like, this is
gonna cost me a lot of money.
And if I'm gonna go out of business,
I just I felt it, I knew that this is
what I needed to do.
- You knew it was right.
- I knew it was right.Yeah, exactly.
And I'm like, you know what (mumbles),
- And not just,
I can already feel your energy,
not just as a wonderful
human being from altruism,
but also having those
instincts of entrepreneur
and things of that nature and saying,
"This is the right thing to do.
And if God Willing something
nice comes out of it
on the back end, then so be it.
And if not so be it.
- Exactly, yeah. It wasn't like
everyone's (mumbles) masks.
- Correct.
- Isn't there like such a fine line
between chronicling and documenting
exactly what you're doing?
'Cause it's the right thing to do. Right?
And then doing it because you want people
to see you doing the right thing?
- Yeah I mean, look, to your point.
One of the things that confuses
people about me so much,
especially my assists and
people that are close to me,
is I'm doing all these nice things,
and I don't bring them up at all.
- Right. You sent me (mumbles) once,
it changed like my whole month.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, it did.
- Thank you. Anyway
keep going.
- So anyways, so yeah, I
started documenting it.
And I was posting to TikTok every day.
I was posting to YouTube.
I was posting to LinkedIn,
like the tutorials
went on YouTube, the--
- Krystal, what's your website,
so we can throw it up
here while you're talking?
- Oh, KrystalDouglas.com just
the way that my name is spelt.
- Awesome keep going.
So anyways, I did it, and it blew up.
I ended up in the New York Times,
I ended up on NPR, like
all of these things.
And I was like, "I didn't expect that."
And then the contracts started coming.
And I've been sewing like
14 hours a day (chuckles)
And I got all of my girls back to work.
And the way that I structure my company,
everybody says that I pay too high.
I pay high because that's what it's worth,
because I do the work and I
know exactly what it takes.
- So my question--
- Plus you're building
your business business.
I pay too high, too,
"I'm paid too low." Sometimes they say,
like, Who gives a shit what they say.
Anytime somebody tells you
you're paying too much.
You tell them look dead
in the face and just say,
"That's very sweet. You worry
about your fucking business."
(laughs)
- Okay, Got it.
- People are like, "Gary,
you pay too much here"
I'm like, "uh."
They are like, "You're
paying too low here."
I'm like, and there's 47, 000 creators
that I can hire supplying them.
It's not super complicated.
I get to choose, like you get
to plan your business salary.
- Yes, exactly. There really aren't
a lot of seamstresses in Nashville.
There's not
- Having anybody tell you
anything about your business
is similar to anybody telling
you on how to raise your kids.
It's a joke. We, me included,
we can talk in the back row,
but in full detail, like you,
that gets silly because one knows that,
unless somebody is asking then you answer,
but I understand.
Don't worry about that.
Don't spend another second on that ever,
ever ever again in your life.
Don't overthink that
- (mumbles) because now I'm slammed
'cause what's so funny.
Is in that initial email.
I was like, if I fail,
I want a job interview at
Chattanooga, VaynerMedia
because I am doing exactly
what you said to do, I swear.
(chuckles)
If I go down, I'm going
down leading the charge.
If I get evicted, I want a job interview.
That's what I want and I didn't fail.
So You don't have to do that.
(chuckles)
- My question--
- First off
funny thing happens,
when people actually do what I'm saying,
which Oh, by the way
is fucking free advice
and they actually do it,
for a sustained period of time,
most times they do not fail.
Sometimes people don't have enough talent
and they're delusional
about what they're up to.
But if they follow it,
it's so tried and true.
It's so tried and true.
- It's so true
- I'm such an old school
tried and true true.
- If anybody's watching
this and they're scared
to actually go full out and play full out,
like I am no one on social media
and those videos have 120, 000 views.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, I mean, look, it's just
so free. It's fucking free.
- Yeah, absolutely. It's amazing.
Well, my question yesterday,
it was how you balance
the things that you wanna
do versus the things
that you need to do, but
then when I woke up today,
the question is now, how do I really build
a profitable business when I
don't care about the money?
- By not building as profitable
a business as you could,
but still make it profitable
enough that it sustains.
It's how I run my businesses.
- And how do I make it profitable enough
where it sustains itself?
'Cause here I'm going (mumbles)
- Yeah, you have to be profitable
or you'll go out of business.
- Right.
- If you wanna be charitable
and this might work for you,
'cause this helped me, if
you wanna be charitable,
be charitable as a human being
with the profits you make.
If you're charitable within your business,
there won't be a business.
- Okay, now I get it.
- You have to make a profit.
You see what I'm saying?
This really helped. I struggled with it.
I did my charitable
work within my business.
I didn't fire people that
deserved to be fired.
I did a lot of things.
And then I realized, well, if one library
goes out of business, and then later,
if VaynerMedia goes out of business,
I'm not doing anything for anybody.
So let me get this profitable, it hurts.
But I transformed into having
that decision making capability.
And I've always had it,
I never was underwater.
I never was losing money,
but you need to have
a little bit of a nest tag to
build a sustainable business.
And then I do a ton of
things I'm very proud of
with my own money after I
take it from the business.
So you're able to do that as well.
- Yeah, I think I'm right there
in that like fine grey area
of you let me want (mumbles)
- Do you struggle with firing people?
- Oh, yeah.
- Let me tell you something
that really really,
it still is and was by far
the hardest thing for me as an operator.
You'll be surprised this
is gonna hurt me saying it
and I think it's gonna help you.
Once you realize that
that's your ego talking,
it's gonna help you a lot.
One of the things that
happens with people like us,
that I'm sensing from you,
is you feel like they're
better off with you,
that you can shelter them
that they're not good--
- They are changed.
- I do this all the time,
they're not good, so if I
let them out into the wild,
they're gonna really suck out there.
- No, noway
I knew you were gonna get this.
So the reality is that's not true.
And what you're doing
is you're building up
subconscious resentment towards them,
which allows you not to
manage them properly.
And you would do them a much
bigger favor by letting them go
and giving them maybe a little
bit bigger severance package
or maybe a month's of pay or something.
Then doing what you're doing right now,
- yeah, okay. Oh, you have no idea
what I'm walking away with.
(laughs)
- I do know, that's why this
format has been so great,
right? Like not having
to be rushed and kind of
trying to go for a fast impact,
like I do on the podcast or Ask Gary Vee.
Like, by spending these few minute,
I could start really
getting a sense of you.
And I was like, Oh, fuck,
I think she's dealing with--
Not only do I know what
you're leaving her with,
as happy as you are with me right now,
'cause you listened then it worked,
what could have been the
worst time of your career
turned into the best.
You're going to love me
even more for this one.
'Cause in two or three years,
you're gonna be just happier.
- Yeah. Can I ask one more question?
- I'm gotta get to everybody else,
we can have you back on next week.
- I just wanna know if you're
doing 4Ds in Chattanooga.
- We will we will. Yes.
We're just trying to figure it out.
But yes, and I'll be there
and then we get to high five it out.
- Right, thank you.
- See yah.
- 4Ds is a daily digital deep dive.
It's a one day consulting
product that we do
at The Sasha Group, which
is the agency that we have.
Shout out to The Sasha Group,
let's throw up The Sasha Group's URL here,
if your a small business, you
should Check out Sasha Group,
It's really interesting
that business is exploding right now,
a lot of people backed out
'cause small businesses now,
have some can't afford a
$50 ,000 Consulting thing
or whatever that they're doing with Sasha
and on the flip side a ton of people
have gone the other way
and have gone heavy there.
So if you're an SMB mid-sized business,
and you're finally ready to do this right,
especially if you work with an agency.
You should definitely go to
Sasha Group and hit us up.
Let's keep this going.
- Joe.
- Hey, Gary, how you doing?
- Really well, what's cooking?
- Glad to hear it.
- So to kinda jump right in,
I took your advice about nine months ago
and I left a job I had in tech sales,
making really good money
to essentially go back
into the golf industry
where golf is my passion.
- Good for you Joe.
- And a completely new position.
I've done like management
and sales my whole life,
and I took over all the
operations for the company.
We're just a small
premium accessory company.
So my question with that is,
So on top of that, I'm
getting mentored by my boss,
and how do you keep that perspective
of moving forward, knowing that
there is that patience part of it,
but also like this, there's some days
where I meant Sitting here working,
I have no idea what I'm doing
just from the standpoint of,
you don't know what you don't know,
operations to me is a
completely new field in general.
- Does it fell right, do
you fel intuitively right?
- Yeah.
- Well, good.
- Yeah, I mean
I think it's one of those things
where I've always loved like,
the sales and the management
side, like coaching,
but the operations I've really
found a passion I really like
- Enjoyable, it's like a game
- Yeah, I really enjoy it.
- Right? It's like a game
- Obsess fun.
I'm super pumped about this question,
'cause it's an easy one.
Like, don't beat yourself up.
It's really as simple as
try and have good intent.
And when you make a mistake,
own it, be accountable.
And try, have good intent,
accountability, try
Like leadership comes with accountability.
- Yeah, I agree.
Just watching business people,
just watching the world like anybody
who blames others at the top
is losing, like a CEO
blaming somebody else,
"Like oh, my general
manager fucked it up."
You hired the general manager.
- I agree. Yeah.
- Everything stems from the top,
like football owners they are like
"You know my general manager,"
But you hired him, "My coach sucks."
You hired the general manager,
and hired the coach like,
If you're not accountable on operations
that's the only vulnerability you have.
Everything else has to be
good intent and effort.
- Yeah, so with that say 100%
agree on the accountability
yet something I tried to really embody
because you have to be accountable.
I find myself almost like you said it's
I find myself beating myself
up from the standpoint of
I've tried taking your advice and
the good and negative comments,
let them kinda just go through the same,
don't really think about it,
but I find myself when as
people I really look up to
like my boss, right?
So he's mentoring me in a lot of ways.
When I do something,
he doesn't beat me up for it,
but it's just like,
okay, you did it wrong.
I almost take it harder
even though it is like,
I'm trying I know I'm
going to like screw up.
So is it just essentially I don't know,
like turn your brain on that.
- Did you golf?
- Yeah.
- Like, fuck man, you're
so set up for this.
Like, what do you cry and
quit on the seven hole,
when you missed a five foot putt?
- No.
- Okay, what are you gonna cry?
When especially you're so lucky.
I was waiting for the shoe to drop,
that the mentor was
not giving the feedback
in a way that was palpable.
And then you drop that the mentor
is dropping the feedback
in a very palpable way.
Which then, it's really funny
when a leader goes nice about it
he almost makes you wanna
rise up even more. Right?
- Yeah,
- let me promise you
something about your mentor
based on what I'm hearing.
She or he?
- He.
He already knows.
Like he knew that you didn't Have 15 years
of operational experience.
- Yeah, it's true.
- He already knew. When I hire people,
and they make all these
different mistakes,
I knew they didn't know how to do it.
When I move people from a
different job into a new job
and they failed miserably.
I'm not upset with them.
I knew that was a risk factor.
He knows bro.
He also knows that you have
the demeanor or the energy,
I can even feel it in this call
to fucking figure it out
over the next three years
you'll be fucking great at it.
- Yeah, I just beat
myself up really quick.
- Stop crying, every second you sit there
and dwell that you let him down
or you're disappointing yourself
is a second that you're not putting in
to figuring out how to be better at it.
- Yeah, it's true.
- I know bro. Listen promised me,
the second you go down that pipe.
Be like fuck if Gary's watching
right now he'd punch me.
Don't let yourself go over there.
It's a complete waste of
time who gives a fuck?
- I agree.
- Who cares?
- No it's great advice. It's true.
- Use what made you good
at golf, to focus on this.
You just can't dwell on the last part
'cause if you do your whole
day is gonna be ruined.
- And you're fucked if you do that.
Yeah same thing.
- That was the first time
in your voice that you had conviction.
Just convert that now into ops.
Bro, I make mistakes every day, big ones.
Now, Gary Vee.
- Yeah, It's true.
- You got this Joe,
You got this
- I appreciate Gary.
- The golf thing, got it
- Awesome I appreciate it.
'Cause that was the
first time in your voice you're like,
"of course." I'm like, "Right?"
'Cause I'm the business version of that.
Like, "Of course." Got it?
- Got it.
- Got it?
- Got it, let's do it
- Good. Thank you Joe.
- Thanks, Gary.
You Got it.
- Fuck man I love this show.
9:37 in the morning.
What's good, what's good, what's good.
Sharon great to see you.
Irene Lb, Dennis Davis wants that punch.
Auntie Ron Don, What's good?
Jerry young, thank you so much.
Thanks for being here.
Calvin Garick thank you
so much for being here.
Mindy Vasquez,
Lyle, what's up, bro?
- Hey boy, hey my man, how you doing?
- One of my favorite,
favorite artists out here.
Let's throw up your website right here,
people need to buy some of your art today.
- So it's a LyleFoxman.com
So check out my work.
- Amazing. How you doing?
- But actually,
Good. Hanging in there.
- Good.
- But actually I wanna
talk about education today,
I went back to teaching in
public school back in the fall.
And we have this big
shift now in education,
where it was structured and rules
and within a matter of two to three weeks,
we had to go from the classroom to online
and the classroom very structured to now
where teachers have to be more creative
and where administrators
and everybody are saying
to be creative and figure it out.
- Daniel we are live.
- Okay, so this fuckin' work
now, this is huge for you.
- Yes. And it's huge for, but I think
and this is way it goes
into my questions is
where teachers now have to do this,
a lot of teachers aren't
comfortable doing that
because they've been for over 100 years
education has been for the workers.
- I get it, you don't want
a fucking thing. Go ahead.
- So how can teachers now and the ones
that are uncomfortable,
take leadership and ownership and changing
a public education system,
especially when we go back?
- They can't.
They can't change the system.
They can just be an
individually great teacher
and play within it.
The biggest problem that
people understand is like
the system change is super macro.
It's on a state and national level.
Plus there's an enormous
percentage of people
within the teachers unions
who don't want it to change.
The way they teach is not
within the system brother,
the way you teach, the way you change it
is outside the system.
That's why I've always one isle,
I don't play within the fucking framework,
I play outside of the fucking framework.
- So what should what
should teachers be doing now
to like change?
- If you're 31 teacher--
Right now they need to be pumping
into the video classrooms
the stuff they want
not what they're forced
to by the curriculum
'cause shit's wild wild west,
- But yeah (mumbles) wild wild west.
- I know, so teach these kids real shit.
Not fucking some shit they
have to fucking memorize.
That's on their fucking phone
that they can regurgitate.
- Yeah, 'cause I had
someone some of the best
one on one interactions with
my students that I've had
since starting back up in the Fall.
- Of course bro. because
the fucking format
of education in the
classroom is horse shit.
It just is. And then
it takes great teachers
to break it within that framework.
And right now you're
outside that framework
where you can break even more.
The first move is a teacher
that goes into a classroom says,
"Fuck this I'm gonna fucking
make these kids lives better."
And does what they do,
And then just kinda just checks the box
for the fucking machine.
The second move is right now,
now the whole system's broken,
you could do all sorts of shit.
And that's where you're
seeing some action,
the third move your master
question is very simple,
21 teachers get together and say,
"Fuck this shit."
find an entrepreneur and some funding,
start a fucking alternative
school and fucking go.
- Right so what--
- You don't have to do it
within the public school system?
- Yeah, so what do you think
education should look like?
I know you didn't like school,
so (mumbles)
- I think education should be individual,
I think we should be reverse engineering
every fucking child and figuring them out
and whether it's
vocational, entrepreneurial,
or proper structured,
old school school system,
lawyer, doctor like human
based, not machine based.
- Exactly.
- But guess what? That's on parents.
It's On fucking parents.
- Funny how you said that
'cause a lot of the
parents are coming back now
it was always like the teachers fault
and a lot of parents are going.
"Oh, I see what you were talking about."
(laughs)
- Remember what I just talked about
with leadership as the last thing.
It's always the parents fault
It's not teacher fucking child,
It's your fucking child.
They're there for seven hours a day
for fucking two thirds of the year.
Get the fuck out of
here with that bullshit.
That's called the lack of
accountability by parents.
You know what they're learning at school.
Tell them to be like me
and be a fucking F student.
And then teach them
some shit after school.
Get the fuck out of here parents.
Fuck out of here parents.
- Yeah, 'cause now they have to sit there
with their child and help them.
- Forget that horse shit,
they're just annoyed by their kids.
That's not what they're worried about.
What they're worried about
is they don't want to be accountable.
People don't want to be
accountable for shit.
Even their children.
Their businesses, their fucking
managing jobs or salaries.
People hate to be accountable.
People love to judge others
for what they suck at.
People don't like to look
at the fucking mirror Lyle.
Once they learn how to look
at the mirror they get happy.
It's Hiding. Come on.
Thank you, bro.
- My son has one question for you
- Okay.
- Come here Jason.
- Jason, Whats good?
- Hi.
- Did you watch WrestleMania?
- Hell yeah. You?
- What do you think of the new format?
- I like fans. I need fans.
But they did a good job.
They did the best they can.
Jayson, What's your
favorite football team?
- My favorite football, Jets.
- Good boy.
Good job Lyle, way to save that one.
Have a great day, Jason.
Give your dad a kiss.
You got a good daddy.
All right take care brother.
All right. Let's see what's going on.
Jesse, What's good?
Monica Torres What's good?
Caleb Ganger, What's good?
Kenneth you could be on this service
by going to Twitter asking your question
and using the hashtag Tea with GaryVee.
And then Somebody from Team Gary Vee's
Twitter account will reach out to you
and find you and get you on
the show in the coming weeks.
David Garcia, What's good? What's good?
Well, I like nice work Dustin.
Let's keep this going.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hey, Laura, How are you?
- Good. I'm so excited to be on with you.
- Thank you.
So, I have like a million questions.
So I'm was trying to, like
combine (chuckles) them.
so I more or less wanna
be a writer, as my career.
I've had a travel blog since 2008.
I wrote a book last year,
I kinda did everything self published,
I wanted to learn everything.
I kinda want to learn the ropes of it all.
So I love that it's great
but the sales are not there.
I sold like 65 copies,
just my own marketing and all that stuff
and what my own platform and all that.
But I have a second one.
And I'm not sure what to do with it,
because--
- You're worried about the sales?
I'm worried about the
sales, but I'm also like,
I wanna get it out there.
Like I want this to really be my career.
And I'm not sure if this is like,
because I get stuck at like,
"I've been doing this
for 12 years tra tra tra"
Like, maybe this is something,
like is there something like
I should keep going with?
Or is it like, "Hey give up."
- 12 years is a real up art.
Like I'm proud of you.
You persevered and hung in.
This is tough to say,
but sometimes, maybe not.
There's a lot of people
who wanna be a rapper,
and they're not good enough.
There's wanna to be actors
and not good enough.
There's people that wanna be
writers and not good enough.
Now, you know, I'm mister optimist,
but I'm also Mr. Practical.
- Right.
I don't think that has to be a bad thing.
Let me tell you why.
I think the energy of it not working
for this period of time.
I've seen a lot of ways sometimes becomes
a self fulfilling prophecy
of not letting it happen.
I believe that if you go and try to jam
on some other stuff that
also makes you happy
be creative, sometimes
that becomes the unlock,
all of a sudden, I could see a scenario
where you start like, fucking starting
a flower podcast 'cause
ironically, you also like flowers,
that creativity gets
going a little something.
But then that triggers the creativity,
you start finding yourself two years later
starting to write a little bit,
and then that popped
off while you're doing.
- Yeah, I mean, I started
writing on elephant journal too,
- Love
- And with a different type of writing
because I don't travel like I used to.
I started this craft when I was 18.
So I'm 30 now, so I've changed so much
in that period of time.
So I actually enjoy that type of writing
so my website is now where it's,
I have my travel when I can
and then I write also
whatever I wanna write about,
but my main thing about my books is like,
how to deal with anxiety and like--
- How much how free content
are you putting out on the internet
with you in video form talking
about those subject matters?
- I actually hate video.
- Why?
- I'm just not about
Video person, like I--
- You're a video person We know
you're doing extremely well.
- I know, but I hate it.
- Why? Are you self
conscious about your looks?
- No, it's not that, I
just don't feel like I have
the personality for it.
- You're wrong.
- I really don't.
You've decided that for
yourself subjectively.
- Yeah, I mean, I guess
it's uncomfortable for me
to kinda like, talk to
myself. You know what I mean?
- Yeah. So what you could do is actually
start a a Zoom or live,
you could go live when
there's other people
like right now Jerry
Young's here and Sunnyshiny
and Robert Blaton that makes
me feel more comfortable,
like regular but like Brian B like,
maybe I mean, I couldn't
disagree with you more.
I've done this a ton and recognize
when people are wildly
uncomfortable with video,
you've arbitrarily from an insecure place
or a subjective place or ideologial place
or just a random thought
place have decided that
- Yeah, but didn't you say too though
'cause I've like followed
you for so many years
and I'm like, huge on your content.
If that's not your strong
suit, should you not?
_ That's right.
- Cause writing you feel it.
- that's right
but I've got a problem with that.
You've given writing 12 years,
you've given video zero fucking days.
I don't know if it's your strong suit
and guess who else doesn't know, you.
- Right. Yeah, no, I got it.
- Well, good, 'cause
that's some real shit.
that's a fun moment.
You might be right, I'm
just intuitive about this
and feel like you could definitely
talk to the video camera.
- Yeah, I would just have to like
I'm sure it's uncomfortable for a bit
but I guess I just--
- Oh my god, watch this.
Are you watching in a way that you can see
comments somewhere?
- Yeah, a little bit.
- Good, real quick, everybody.
How many of you are
doing video now like it
but hated it at first?
Go give me a yes.
I promise you you're
about to be blown away.
So many people struggle with it at first.
But like you're gonna see
so many yeses right now
because like people, I mean
almost everybody by the way.
There's actually, most people are.
I mean, look at this, this
is fucking ridiculous yes.
- Yeah, but I guess so my
other quick question though is
because I have this second book
and it's for like anxiety for teens
'cause a lot of kids are struggling--
- You need to make three videos a day
on TikTok about anxiety
for teens for four months,
and then when you put the book out,
It'll fucking sell like crazy.
This is why we're having this convo.
- Yeah, but do you think
there's a difference
between self publishing or traditional
or it doesn't matter?
- No, both win both loose.
I think nobody knows who the fuck you are.
And then when you try to sell
something, it's hard to sell.
- Yeah, because the problem is,
I've gotten a lot of feedback
over the years of like,
"Oh, I love your stuff.
"I love your stuff." But then I'm like,
"But it's not showing in sales."
Or it's not showing in like numbers.
You know what I mean?
I'm like, What the fuck am I doing wrong?
- What you're doing wrong is not building
a personal brand to leverage against.
Meanwhile you're also crushing
this video conversation.
Everyone's going crazy.
(laughs)
No seriously, don't do this to yourself.
I want you to make two
to three fucking videos
on TikTok a day about anxiety.
And like in three months
you'll have a real audience
of young adults that they
will wanna buy your book.
Like we're fucking in the
prime moment of being able
to get to that audience 'cause of TikTok.
It's a fucking gift. You
wont open the fucking gift.
It's a gift, you wont open it.
- I know, I was starting to
play with it a little bit
and put out like, I'm just messing with it
to try to get it out there just trying.
- But you're not putting yourself in it.
- No, not necessarily.
But I mean I posted one
I got like 400 views and I
was like this shit's insane.
- So what the fuck are we doing here?
- I don't (laughs) don't know.
- What's your Instagram?
- It's traveljerzeygirl but
it's spelled J-E-R-Z girl
- Okay. Dustin find that pin
that I want everybody to--
How many followers do you have?
- Like 1850 I think.
- Nice cell number.
Good. Let's get that up.
- No it's J-E-R-Z no Y ?
- No Y Dustin?
(laughs)
- Just a quick question--
- Laura What part of Jersey
are you from?
- I'm actually from Edison New Jersey.
I'm from the same town.
- That's amazing. What
High school did you go to?
- And did you? No he spelt it wrong?
I know Dustin.
(laughs)
- Go ahead Laura
- Do you know Edison high school?
- Yeah, I would have went to JP Stevens.
- Oh, we didn't like you.
- I know, I'm aware. But good news.
I moved right before High
School to Huntingdon County,
so I went to Huntingdon high school.
Laura listen to me you're making
a huge fucking mistake.
- Yeah all right.
Well I haven't.
- You are not all right,
Like we need to talk this through.
- No, I mean, listen, we're
all fucking quarantined,
so I have nothing but time
so I might as well just say, "Fuck it."
And try it, right?
- Look, like Beth wants
to follow you so bad
like people want to.
Listen to me you're Jersey
girl you can do this.
Going through Edison high is way harder
than fucking making a TikTok.
(laughs)
- Well, I also because I
feel like I resonate with you
so much because we're
from Jersey and I knew
you were from Jersey
somehow 'cause that like,
the cursing thing and like the Jerseyness
I'm like, No, he's from Jersey,
but I also feel like, I'm
sure you've had the same thing
where it's like, "Hey you
shouldn't curse so much."
And I'm like
that's mean though.
- But yes,
well fuck them exactly.
I promise you be fully you
on TikTok three times a day.
Really get into the culture of TikTok
what kind of videos to make.
Laura listen to me these
young girls and guys need you.
Don't do this for me.
Don't do this for you do that for them.
Making 3 videos do it for them.
Now you have 2045 followers on Instagram.
What's your TikTok?
- it's the same thing
traveljerzgirl across the board?
- Twitter?
- Twitter same?
- Do you have a YouTube?
- I do not but I have (mumbles)
- 'Cause you don't make videos.
- No, I tried back in the day I tried
and I was like no fuck
that I'm not about it.
- Listen to me I'm telling you,
this moment was for this.
Corona happened so we could talk
- I agree
- So good. You're a fucking Jersey girl
you should not have a problem with this,
I mean that.
- I know
- You could do this.
- Tell me some real shit,
Tell me why you're not doing.
Is there anything I'm
not thinking about like,
weird stalker boyfriend or fucking bad--
I'm being really real with you.
I want you to win so I want to know
- It's just uncomfortable honestly,
- I think intuitively,
I think you can break through
- Yeah and I honestly think
it's just like a like--
- And Laura really quick before you finish
'cause I want everybody hear this,
I swear to God I don't
do this all the time.
There's a lot of calls I do.
There's a lot of people I interact with.
I don't push them all the time,
'cause I don't always think they can.
There're some weird fuckers out there.
but I really think you can do this.
- Yeah. I mean, 'cause I
want like with my books too,
'cause I've struggled with anxiety too.
So it's just like, it's
very personal to me.
So I just feel like between--
- I need you to be more
vulnerable in your videos then
and put them on TikTok help these kids.
- Yeah. Okay.
- I'm telling you right now,
you can't imagine how
huge you can get on TikTok
with this truth, with this Jerseyness,
once you get going, like
so I talked to somebody
the other day and she's a little bit more
of a comfortable content creator.
It literally took her four hours
she DMed me she is like you
fucking changed the game for me
already I'm killing it.
Like voice impressions, different things.
There is so much cool shit going on there.
I think you can find your
spot I'm telling you.
- Right. I believe you.
- Are you gonna do it, or
you're like bullshit dousing me?
- No, I will. I mean,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I am very uncomfortable
about trying to do it.
But I'm gonna play with it and see
I mean I have nothing
to lose at this point.
- There's nothing to lose,
what's gonna happen you're like fucking
your like best friend from college
and be like "Oh you
fucking suck at TikTok."
- I don't give two fucks
about that(mumbles)
- So listen, that's what I believe
like I'm systematically going through
the cliche reasons one doesn't?
No I'm not stuck.
I almost feel like, you
just fucking decided.
- Yeah, but things change right?
- Yeah you can undecide.
- Yeah (chuckles)
- Laura do this please.
Do me a favor Promise me this,
because everyone's following you right now
and so they're gonna tell me tomorrow
that you fucking bullshitted.
- I know that's why (laughs)
- Yeah it's over.
- It's making me nervous (mumbles)
- Yeah you are in deep shit now,
everyone's watching and
everyone's following you now,
so tomorrow they're all gonna be back
'cause I'm back ,
I'm about to wrap up here at 9am
I can't wait to see all of you back.
We're all following you.
- Yeah, I'm gonna put my whole team on it.
- No pressure right?
- I need you to make two
or three TikToks today.
And two or three Instagram,
make an Instagram video where
you just talk about things.
- Okay.
- You can do this.
- I'm uncomfortable as fuck, but Okay.
- I like that because the most
uncomfortable as fuck shit
usually leads to the best shit.
- Yeah.
- By the way they need to hear you,
you you can help them.
Do you understand that if
you get serious about TikTok
you're gonna save a child's life?
- I know I mean it's--
- Well you're not saving shit
with 65 bullshit books sold
on fucking Amazon Laura.
- Well, yeah,
- Are you looking at me?
Do you understand right now?
- Yeah.
- So here's what's really gonna happen,
listen to me you go on
TikTok you go fucking ham.
You're gonna build a real
fucking audience I promise you.
I can feel it with my whole fucking soul.
A, you're going to save
kids lives in that content.
B, a bunch of them are gonna buy books
which is gonna make you happy
'cause you've been wanting
to be a fucking writer
for your whole life.
And there's gonna be a fucking
self fulfilling prophecy
of fucking good versus you
decided you don't do it
and nothing fucking happens.
- Right.
- I mean, and those 64 books,
you know fucking a half of
the people that bought it.
- Yeah,
- Two thirds uncle Lou
bought fucking 20 of them.
So let's fucking get serious here, Laura.
- Okay.
- TikTok to the fucking face.
- Okay. I mean, I don't
even know what the hell
I would say but--
- I'm gonna tell you what to do right now.
You're gonna go and right
now literally hang up
and watch three, four hours of TikTok,
literally watch, click the trending topics
go in your feed for you page
and just watch, watch, watch.
You're gonna see trends
you're gonna be like,
"oh, everyone's doing this."
Okay, my way of talking about that
through the lens of anxiety.
I'm gonna make this video.
You're gonna fucking figure it out.
I believe in you. You're creative.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Aright. Thank you so much (chuckles).
- You're welcome so much.
- All right. Thank you.
- Talk to you soon.
What an episode I hope
everybody enjoyed it
now I go to speak to 1500
executives in a humongous company.
So I'm gonna go into that stream,
some old school software,
none of this tremendous stream yard.
Anyway, real quick. Last pitch.
I got you dad,
last pitch put it up
right here WineText today.
If I'm bringing you value
there's nothing evening for me,
it's not empathy it's for pops,
for my dad who I love the most.
Please sign up for wineText today.
Today 50 plus dollar pinot noir
that's bonkers for
under 25 bucks a bottle.
It's gonna sell out
probably within 30 minutes.
So when you get the text do it.
Please sign up for WineText.
If you do, when you get the
confirmation thank you screen
post it on Twitter I wanna
follow you as a thank you.
I love you.
Dustin, thank you so much
for the ones and twos.
We'll be back tomorrow full time.
Good show today, Dustin.
- Very good show for one hour.
We've got a lot in there.
- That last one huh?
- Yeah.
Dustin, are you signed up for WineText?
- I am but I don't drink wine.
(laughs)
- Well then, dude, unsubscribe.
- I know.
- I don't need to fucking pay for you,
It costs money to send a text dick.
- I know, I know
(laughs)
- Fuck Dustin.
- I'm hoping one day maybe.
- Get the fuck out of here
unsubscribe.
(laughs)
I'll talk to you later, See yah everybody